jamais ceci dit qu'on salue la mémoire
de jean claude joly qui était l'un des
candidats de la saison 16 qui s'est
donné la mort donc on pense évidemment à
ses proches c'était assez tragique crois
pas qu'il ya un lien forcément avec
l'émission mais on voulait évidemment
salué sa mémoire on va faire un petit
récap et ensuite vous aurez les notes
des chroniqueurs qui sont assez
éclectiques ça va de 0 à 10 e croire
regarder
s'est passé beaucoup de choses dans la
dernière saison de l'amour est dans le
pré une bonne occasion donc de revenir
sur les meilleurs moments bachand suis
sur le cul ce sera régaler cette saison
avec des personnages hauts en couleur
comme hervé le plus de quarante trois
ans qui a commencé l'aventuré timidement
mais
c'est
[Musique]
que dire de plus il faut dire qu'il
s'est bien rattrapé le gouffre et il a
même découvert qu'il était en fait
barafi pour le sexe je crois que j'ai
été j'étais très bon on a découvert
valentin l'agriculteur un petit coin les
interpellons première rencontre avec les
proches de sa prétendante et le matin on
est tous qu'elles notent
voici tous monter quelqu'un on attend
qu'elle matin
il fait des blagues parfois un peu
rentrer dedans mais c'est comme il est
c'est lui qui a bien galéré c'est
surtout jean-françois quels droits de
cette chanson d'amour au public il n'y
avait pas de pleurs qui n'avait pas de
réseau mon âme sans
y avait aussi vincent à séducteur en
cours d'eau qui a passé huit folie avec
ce jeune prétendante speed mais avec
mais peut-être arriver mais bon une fois
qu'il a fini sa petite affaire il a dit
sur buybuy j'ai du mal à me projeter
mois
allez comme si j'analyse tout chez moi
c'était une belle saison on s'est rendu
compte que la bourse toujours
non doucement en fait je me suis grattée
les faits
et la prochaine saison
n'était pas les autres la prochaine
réunion s'annonce très bien puisque je
crois que les portraits bon et on fait 3
millions 39 min et sculpteur en moyenne
donc ça fonctionne très bien fait bon
alors malheureusement il y en a qui
aiment unis autour de la table où je
vais vous faire parler
on va comment ça va causer d'exil moi je
suis un déçu de l'émission mais je
l'adorais cette émission parce que non
ma famille a beaucoup d'agriculteurs y
ait une extrême solitude parmi ces gens
là et je trouve que ça permettait de les
mettre en valeur mais c'est devenu une
caricature c'est devenu une télé réalité
il ya plus d'authenticité c'est des gens
qui viennent chercher le buzz tout est
faux on a l'impression que c'est presque
fabriquer scénarisé donc ça m'a beaucoup
déçu c'est pour ça que j'ai mis une note
de 2 ha alors c'est pour préserver les
catastrophiques on
n'a pas la même
j'aimerais ne pas l'avoir comme juste de
patiner
ne connaît pas les causes vous vous
aimez bien ces missions vous ai mis une
belle c'est exactement pour l' inverse 1
c'est du mépris non pardon 8
ces fonds des gens qui étaient renfermés
sur eux qu'on a mis en lumière alors
effectivement cantoria un petit peu de
caricatures beaucoup sont des gens qui
sont dans une extrême souffrance et
grâce à cette émission on a pu les
mettre en valeur alors après je
reconnais que ces deux dernières années
il ya eu un peu de caricatures pas
capable de tendance on a un peu tendance
à peser oui mais adresse ce sont les
règles aussi c'est une émission c'est
une émission un peu de télé réalité
aujourd'hui alors
je vous coupe ils ne vendaient pas du
tout de cette émission l'avant dès le
berceau des mets en mai sa stratégie
c'est stratégique de la part de la
chaîne qui continue à faire des scores
de 2 3 millions de téléspectateurs on
est je crois la dix septième saison on
arrive on aspire à terre les oignons ça
en moyenne c'est 4 millions cent oui
face énorme en tout 29 novembre 2000 21
c'est énorme
qui n'a jamais non seulement n'a pas n'a
pas baissé mes choix mieux que ça a
monté mais oui c'est un moment c'est
absolument incroyable et qui est
indépendante de l'animation parce qu'il
ya trois animatrices ya quatre millions
cent alors qu'on était à trois millions
quatre ans de jeu je ne comprends pas
pourquoi
ou alors vous madame alors vous vous
aimez bien moi j'aime j'aime beaucoup
abandonnés là
gmail vous voyez pas pas non
habitant y est plus naturel que l'autre
je sais pas laquelle
a donné 8 parce que je viens de la
campagne je sais ce que c'est
l'agriculture et c'est un métier
difficile c'est peu dire j'ai une fois
voulu passer une journée entière avec un
ami qui fait des qui fait des bovins et
tout ça au bout de trois heures j'avais
pleuré je fais des vaches est en fait
j'avais envie de pleurer tellement
c'était difficile alors la charrette et
le lâcher ensuite ça ensuite si ensuite
ça c'est horrible arrête c'est un
avantage
énorme attend
[Applaudissements]
on n'imagine pas tout le travail qu'il
ya derrière les céréales et toute
l'agriculture donc pour ça j'aimerais
leur tirer voilà mon chapeau et cette
émission permet de les mettre en lumière
donc je trouve ça très bien parce que
clairement c'est pas des journées de 12
heures qui fonce et des journées de 24
heures ils ont derrière vacances et
maubeuge est élevé à la campagne quand
on voit qu'on peut penser donc j'ai
connu vraiment les annonceurs et que
j'ai vécu moi ça n'a rien à voir ce que
je vois dans cette émission mais
absolument rien alors allez-y madame
alors moi j'ai pas dame madame berda oui
je m'appelle magali berdaoui jeune
chanteur fait moi j' adore déjà oui
c'est une émission de télé réalité très
clairement il faut dire ou à un chat un
chat ou un chien chien fr ou un mouton
un mouton mais bon bref un
génial c'est que c'est une des premières
émissions télé réalité justement qui a
ouvert ses portes à la cause lgbt et qui
a accepté d'avoir des couples
homosexuels c'est pas les premières la
promesse qu'il ait fait un certain b c
ouais c'est dans le loft de m6 comme ah
oui occupe wood cas ben oui c'est bien
ça remonte à ya vingt ans donc
il fallait le faire il ya 20 ans mais
oui je suis d'accord mais oui mais là
aujourd'hui c'est aussi sur ce cas les
réseaux sociaux il ya beaucoup de
critiques etc et j'ai pu relever maté
alex par exemple battu alexandre votre
formidable et qu'ils sont vrais
contrairement à ce que tu dis c'est pas
du fait que moi j'ai eu l'occasion de
les rencontrer et même de travailler
avec eux ces gens qui m'impressionne
qu'ils savaient beaucoup d'eric il va en
tout cas pas vu donc c'est qu'il ya
quand même du dre merci magali c'est pas
mal à remonter
j'aime ici je vais vous dire pourquoi
parce que d'abord effectivement c'est un
coup de projecteur sur un métier qu'on
ne connaît pas qui est extrêmement
difficile moi j'ai beaucoup de sympathie
pour toutes ces personnes qui sont
seules qui ont envie de se rencontrer
donc je ne peux pas juger la solitude
des gens comme ça alors d'une façon ou
d'une autre on se rencontre au travers
d'une émission ou pas je trouve ça très
bien donc moi ça me plaît bon maintenant
il est vrai que c'est trop scénarisé ils
organisent les trucs qui sont pénibles
sans un peu lourdaud moi je suis très
séduit par karine le marchand qui a
vraiment un charme fou et oui oui oui
j'adore karine le marchand
elle est devenue lc je trouve que son
animation s'est détériorée au fil des
saisons elle est devenue elle-même
caricatural est ce que la juge eut l'air
parfois la raison à présent mais le
problème pas qu'elle soit charmante mais
ce sera agréable à la cadière
l'animation s'est améliorée si elle est
mineure de l'empathie ça si oui c'est de
lancer
mais voici deux tempêtes alors justement
on va demander à lui qui adore le
programme alors j'adore le programme et
j'ai donné je pense que la note qu'elle
méritait vraiment cette émission mérite
un gros zéro point qui doit lui ni le
pourquoi un peu jalouse de qui de quoi
du dégât
je vous explique et je revois énormément
l'analyse de gilles j'avais énormément
de 2,2 d'espoir lors des prémices de
lance de lancement de cette émission je
pensais que c'était une véritable
émission de biens publics pour faire du
bien pour le faire non seulement
découvrir le monde de l'agriculture mais
pour permettre également que des
personnes qui seraient dans la même
situation de deux hits de solitude se
rencontrent mais en fait à l'issue de la
première saison j'ai compris que c'était
la plus grosse supercherie de la
télévision ever pourquoi parce qu'en
fait on propose aux petits bobos
parisiens à l'ensemble des français de
sortir leur pop-corn et leur petit
plateau télé pour se [ __ ] de la gueule
des personnes non des civils bien sûr
que si combien de fois il ya des
personnes qui trouvera la portance
unique en syrie puis en postillonnant
sur une caméra ça n'arrive pas et en
fait malheureusement c'est ce qu'aime 6
a décidé de choisir comme comme parti
pris pour se [ __ ] de la gueule des
gens moi j'ai hâte que quelqu'un
récupère le programme est l'essence même
du programme pour leur [ __ ] une belle
une belle année dans la tête et que ce
programme disparaissent c'est que
j'allais pas d'accord ainsi nicolas
d'accord pour deux raisons d'abord tu es
obligé de scénariser cette émission dont
pays tient à un moment donné le truc
c'est de voir des agriculteurs qui ont
tous les mêmes souffrances tous les
mêmes problèmes de manière si ça
n'intéressera pas les gens alors de
temps en temps c'est naturel c'est
naturel 6 me en temps normal alors quand
il
ya de tels appels il ya peut-être un
curseur à remettre en place de la
démission disparaissent quand une
émission c'est après 17 ans 4 millions
de téléspectateurs
c'est un moment donné c'est que
l'émission allait populaire elle sert à
quelque chose c'est une émission de
biens publics la cm mayans entre nous ça
aurait pu être une émission de service
public ça va plus je saurai plus ça a eu
plus ouais ça ne valait pas mais qu'est
ce qu'elle a contre leslie mois chance
et pas la maison
[Applaudissements]
mais
franchement je n'aime pas l'émission
parce que j'ai l'impression aux gens ont
ri aux dépens mais six avions dépensé
aurait pas avec eux il fallait finir une
très bonne note bien sûr un
nom mais ces démissions c'est alors moi
j'habite du côté à côté de saint-jean
nuit donc à sketches et jusqu'au les je
vois les moutons mater les paysans et
ses chances et je trouve que l'émission
elle et moi je dirais c'est comme le
gazon synthétique c'est pas naturel
voilà c'est pas moi ça ne représente pas
voilà le côté agriculture tout ça donc
c'est plus mon coeur moi je me sens
quand on regarde ça et malheureusement
c'est vrai et il ya des émissions qu'on
regarde pour se [ __ ] de la gueule des
gens et moi j'ai des émissions où je
rigole bien les a remplis terre regarde
ça et je pense qu'il ya quand même une
majeure partie des gens c'est pas
méchant mais c'est une émission qui
porte à rire quand même ça va à présent
d'ailleurs on vous l'a fait petit lynx
amérique on vous a fait une petite
sélection des deux extraits vous
rappelez de herve le plus rigolo
alors il ne l'est plus d'ailleurs
justement ce qu'on est des bruits c'est
un faux débat le débrief c'est tout dans
la légèreté ah oui c'est sûr je me sens
très bien je suis heureuse on va passer
une belle me oui on va dire que c'était
intense où les patrons des cox a elle
aussi vite craint c'est vrai que ma vie
où je suis prêt je crois que j'ai été
j'étais très bon
ça va être rapide mais non pas du tout
c'est pas du tout le déception banon et
je m'y tiens tu vas manger quand vrai
breton non plus
et puis un moment je suis à allumer la
lumière voilà quoi je trouvais pas une
photo
[Rires]
c'est pour possible d'aimer site
pourtant du
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
gard et la poésie dans tout ça
alors justement stéphanie donc stéphanie
et et hervé vous parle évidemment des
des anciennes et de des zeks et elle a
une façon bien à elle de tirer un trait
ou de tourner la page regarder hervé
pense déjà au dessert mais avant cela
stéphanie a besoin d'exprimer ce qui lui
reste sur l'estomac
donc ça c'est mon ex mon ex mois dernier
voilà choisi la suite ce qui est logique
d'accord voilà quand je les ai vu
qu'elle est libérée au fur et à mesure
et quand on est plaisir tu laissé faire
jusqu'à la dernière mais j'étais étonné
que les peaux fait on veut dire bien
avant bien bien bien avant pour pouvoir
se reconstruire plus facilement passer
la dernière
allez-y
je crois que j'avais besoin de ça aussi
vraiment voilà quoi ça m'a vidé c'était
un geste pour moi en fait parce que bon
j'avais besoin de ça pour montrer que
voilà c'était fini et puis lui pour
montrer que j'étais prête pour lancer
dans une nouvelle relation qu'a eu
l'homme de ma vie et c'est lui
[Applaudissements]
moi c'est je suis je rends donc les
albums de laquelle on a pour 8 heures un
tu dois faire
d'abord j'ai pas aimé comme archi c'est
totalement scénariste et
zouaoui même de jeter des photos des
anciens amours c'est
la chemise bleue oui c'est grave quand
même ça veut dire qu'à chaque fois
qu'elle ait eu un mec elle dit on va
faire une séance photo avec elle à la
même pose non mais c'était le même mais
ces termes elle
s'est passé c'est pas moi c'est pas non
plus
les émissions que j'ai regardé alors
donc on va essayer dans la légèreté et
la classe le moment où hervé stéphane et
stéphanie prennent le petit déj après un
week-end amoureux vous savez que tout
passe tout lasse sauf la classe
1 goutte la peur
en es tu veux me faire confiance à
tu vas me faire confiance je vais pas
faire de bêtises j'aimerais pas que le
sas
[Musique]
non doucement pas les dents
en fait je me suis grattée les faits
ses salariés
en faire de même
vous me direz
on l'a dit on l'a dit pas merci de
renard ça on adore le chocolat dans la
bouche on a tous dit un truc
alors que tu fais un choix risqué de
nutella ouais on va garder ça les miens
avant la moyenne oppose les missions
vous l'avez donné l'amour est dans le
pré une moyenne de 4 dago terme mais
année scolaire c'est pas la bonne pour
finir que le 022 divine et le 1 et le 2
km